a Dutch company has invented the world's
first electronic
joint that's right a Dutch manufactures
E-Njoint claim that be the spliff
I is totally harmless contains no
tobacco nicotine
or even THC so just to be clear what's
going on here
is tthe that's the part that sort of the
mental high this can make you laugh and
all that
but the stuff that had the medicinal
benefit is not so you can get the
medicinal benefits without having the
other part of it
with an image %uh the E jointly EN
join it looks like an e-cigarette
basically but nice marijuana leaves the
you know what you do in there not to
confuse you
job it's got the the shape Abril join
obviously
a chrome-plated tip where the cannabis
need lights up with every puff
it's available in 6 proof labors and
they're currently at ten thousand at
these things
sold every day in Europe and
you know they want to get rid of course
at to Amsterdam where we'd is already
legal
although they've been taken back from a
right on that arm pretty good
right this this seems all good we got no
probably to the stable I hope
in I'm surprised a personal always be
Wade to you know invaded the Dutch you
know they and their the one
attacks in prague that's done in tax
prostitutes you know they're they're
like let's
hey there's a supply arthur's the
there's demand let's apply it
and that's what they're doing here on
surprise and there's only six players
yeah the president literally have the
Union yeah there in a union and they
have to go
for STD testing yeah every so often only
when it doesn't it makes money off it so
this could be another example that arm
so if you took the mental high and this
was just
medicine oh there any real is there
anything wrong with this at any level
you can be but I don't think there's
anything wrong with just we'd anyways
but I mean like a few to benefit to this
if there's like a child or something you
know that would need the medical
benefits right something without getting
high
you know obviously you know you don't be
like oh you're littlejohn take this weed
to smoke it
but if it helps them you know really
pain then I'm totally
agree with that but whatever first for
this article to be on a play I can allow
to love them like it
okay folks got no nicotine got no
tobacco it got no THC
but it's got like this marijuana leaf on
people like getting on fight about what
alguna of a new thing i've a first-ball
I feel like China joins for a long time
so this isn't like something that was
newer shocking to me right but the fact
that they're able to take out all those
things and use it for purely medicinal
purposes
is exciting yeah that's a good thing do
we need this in america
I or do we just need to get or do we
just need to get legalize period the way
it's going from state to state right now
and the exact we should legalize period
like many other
taxing prostitution sup why do we tax
marijuana me know when you're
help so many things yeah Detroit take
some notes of Amsterdam rel innovative
you know fine fine new business ventures
dressed in their cutting off water in
Detroit as we did in another segment
where maybe a little weed profiteering
yaaay
right be good for taxing the hookers a
lot in Detroit yeah what do you make of
the people that
iced cans at some level even though I
don't agree with them I can somehow get
the people that don't want
people to be stoned could even be stupid
in driving I don't agree with it and if
there's nothing true about it but
but what about the people that are still
saying no for medicinal
purposes well that to you when I was a
gateway everything is a caring the game
is an enigma
eyeballs a gateway to regular food yeah
yeah I think the only way to really a
takeaway weed in the day which isn't
something else would begin only like
at it is don't see it as as crazy
especially since there's nothing
end this that would be addictive that
would be a gateway to anything what it's
not even get you high
yeah you know it's like pretty much
taking medicine so is it because big
farm is now behind this year is that the
idea because we love everything in pill
form
so they were medicinal benefits to this
in in this form
until big farmers behind it you know we
never get the marketing to get everyone
ginned up for him
maybe two degrees people mostly to be
convinced to things like they think that
all might have had a marijuana leaf on
it
yeah p but it looks like that profit off
and I think I think once you get a big
company behind in manufacturing and just
like big tobacco in the eighties in the
ninety is
and fis error and the other big drug
companies once you get a big corporation
mind his
you know donating money into a major
political campaigns
everyone's gonna be back on board
especially is as you guys are saying
there's no actual negative side effects
that impair judgment
right from what firmware smoking after
they're telling us that if their talent
yeah and I we gotta believe iraq
did with that appeal to you to smoke
something that you would get so did not
have the the mental
stuff we but just get the physical stuff
you know your shoulder and he's not that
you feel a little better instead taking
Advil or something
choice Hollywood you know what the THC
in there and that you take a at a rapid
may be sprinkled on top
yeah morning call their yeah that'll be
something inject
marijuana's yeah alright yeah legalized
for god sakes every week with the week
my kids
up